[Music]
[Applause]
okay I take it back there's one more
thing I want you to just try this week
it doesn't even have to work I just just
to just see how you do um we learnt we
were talking about forward split time
crossing boom so you're on then that's
your definite homework I want you to
figure that out for the session but also
just experiment with yourself with no
pressure getting the play going
backwards split time and seeing if you
can get them crossing backwards foot
time so you've already maybe got
together crossing at the same time and
now I want you to try from a split time
and if it's split time they come over to
the left to cross or both to the right
to cross so if you're trying to cross
both arms together it'll just bring you
back in the same time so get it split
time and just play with that you know
just try to dismantle it a bit
I can have my right come over to chase
the left and the left goes under or I
can have my left come chase right and
the right goes under right I can just go
over here and be like I wonder what
happens oh I see what could come over
here and I can really go you know don't
be afraid it's you're allowed I give you
total permission to like do all kinds of
crazy mess you up you things with this
just we're gonna come back to this next
week but I want you to at least start
priming your brain for the potential so
record split time you're gonna try and
this side try and this side it might
make sense right away it might just Cris
your brain in a knot don't worry we're
gonna get untwisted
but promise me you're going to have at
least a sense of humor about it while
you do it
[Applause]
[Music]